robin hood reported their q3 earnings
and disclosed a 35 decrease in top line
revenue from q2
robin hood stock is currently down about
nine percent and after hours trading
q3 revenue uh was 365 million that's up
35 year over year which puts you in the
high growth category but it's down 35
from the monster quarter they had last
quarter which was 565 million dollars
and so when you look at this chart here
we have a little chart if you're
watching the youtube channel of the live
stream you can see this incredible
run-up during the pandemic the company
grew like wildfire people had stimmy
checks people were obsessed with crypto
you kind of knew there was going to be a
spike
and now things have come back down to
earth people are going back to work
maybe they're not day trading as much uh
so
a little bit of a retreat but if you
compare year over year which is what you
really want to compare as an investor
and the next quarter will be critical
because you're going to want to look at
year over year for the next quarter and
year over year for this quarter are they
still growing and then you could take
those two quarters q1 and q2 and you
could chalk those up to being just
runaway quarters
that you know might not be easily
repeatable so
they had a net loss of 1.3 billion
and last year their q3 was essentially
break even you know some pretty heavy
losses here obviously they're investing
in the business q3 uh average revenue
per user rpoo 65 a user that's great but
it's down uh from the 102 dollars a user
uh year over year because again uh
people who were maybe more actively day
trading
so uh if we look at uh
q3s the monthly active users retreated
as well 18.9 million now this is up 76
year-over-year so remember we talked
about yesterday facebook having a
declining users but uh some growth in
revenue
here we have a 76 year-over-year growth
in users that's extraordinary um but
it's down 12 from q2 because you
remember
everybody opened up accounts when they
saw the game stop and stunks and amc all
this stuff was national news everybody
was talking about robin hood and uh they
also had their ipo so that drives a lot
of interest in the company
so if you compare that to other
contemporaries the old ones like charles
schwab they have 32.7 million and
fidelius 26 million retail accounts so
this upstart is now right behind
uh charles schwab and fidelity
and you you do expect that some people
will in a really hyper
frothy market you know go check out apps
we've seen it before uh where people get
excited about an app it's in the press
they try it but they're not like the
ideal customer profiles the assets under
custody is 95 billion that's up over 115
year-over-year
down slightly from q2 which was 102
billion this is a very significant
statistic as well this means how much
do all the accounts have in them
combined and so
super revealing that this is a you know
a lot of money to be the custodian of
vlad noted that this corridor
was focused on developing new features
and this is critical because
uh when a company grows this fast let's
face it the wheels can come off uh
things can break
have customer support problems which we
saw at coinbase
you know had national news cnbc talking
about people having their accounts
hacked and there's no phone number and
obviously coinbase um did make some
changes and got some phone numbers going
for account resets
so these companies really grew faster
than anybody ever anticipated you know
getting to 20 million users my god 20
million accounts is crazy
unprecedented so a little retreat and a
little bit of like maybe cleaning up uh
shop and building some infrastructure
here is a really good move for startups
that are growing too fast we saw uber do
it airbnb many people have gone through
this where things were moving really
fast and you said you know what we need
to sure things up and make sure this is
built to last and i believe robin hood
airbnb uber these are all built to last
companies it feels like that to me one
of the big efforts they're going to have
is this crypto wallet and so robinhood
announced that uh in late september vlad
announced that the waitlist was already
over a million users and this is
critically important when you have a
huge base of users you can launch
products that are adjacent to yours and
that will then you don't have to acquire
a customer for that service you just
shows up in your app so when i use
wealthfront at some point they put
margin loans in or 529's i had andy
randcleff andy radcliff on here many
times on the show and he talked about
that strategy we just want to keep
releasing new features this is similar
to google releasing chrome gmail buying
youtube android i have all these google
search users google docs gets put in
your interface even google plus got put
in your interface and been removed
because they're so terrible
it actually was a great product but it
should have had its own domain name
that's another that's a story for
another time
uh so robin hood introduced crypto
trading in 2018
uh and in 20 q3 crypto trading accounted
for 51 million of transaction based
revenue about 14 of total revenue so
robinhood clearly uh wants to boost its
crypto presence and that's why they're
making this crypto wallet
uh robin it offers no fee crypto trading
which they can use to market against
coinbase which is staggeringly expensive
i think is what i hear from most people
who trade crypto 1.5 fee on all
transactions uh using a bank account so
you know that's staggering but i think
for crypto folks they feel it's high
coinbase has 68 million verified
accounts so that's verified that's not
necessarily monthly
so you could have many verified accounts
and then maybe you know people are
huddling and not using them every month
so they're reporting on two different
numbers there but clearly coinbase has
done an extraordinary job uh they're
also vlad noted they're gonna do live 24
7 phone support
and
that's going to be a big game changer
doing 24 hours seven days a week is
coming over the top
and basically providing more than you
know a lot of other services do where
you have to call during business hours
uh they announced in a press release
that robin hood would be offering
retirement accounts in the future this
means they're going to go up against
betterment wealthfront which we have a
position in and so
you'll start to see all of these
different financial services
you know kind of race towards a
singularity a banking account a checking
account an atm card a visa card all of
these things are going to be offered in
all of these services it's just so clear
to me it's just a matter of the
prioritization and how good they are how
much they delight users one really cool
thing they did was they were using say
technologies which is uh
was acquired in august of 2021 and they
took a handful of questions from retail
investors which
typically only the banks ask questions
during these calls
so they're really still on that mission
to democratize
so
if as a robin hood shareholder i believe
this company will be worth 10x in 10
years that's why i'm holding my shares
great management team loyal customer
base incredible product design it's not
an accident when somebody gets to 10 or
20 million accounts it's not an accident
when somebody builds a world
changing beautiful app so when i see
that whether it's uber airbnb tesla you
don't bet against great product and
founders still at the company running
those companies making those great
products and so robinhood airbnb uber
you know all have world-class products
uber doesn't have the founder there
anymore so that would be a little mini
red flag um so take that for what it's
worth but i think they got a pretty good
ceo uh who's been doing a pretty good
job of getting them focused on what
matters and i think their earnings will
be in november they're a little bit
behind everybody else this is the big
week for earnings